I must say I was not always the most
talented musician uh but I put a lot of
effort in it and I believe that we can
can make it one day but there were
situations I was questioning myself if
we really will make it specifically when
I was practicing I don't mean new song
or part in the song and I could not
really make progress so and I remember
there was one specific situation and I
must tell you what I'm not tell you is
um I never heard about this before um
but I know that you guys you know in
your ministry have shown many Clips when
it comes to people who say that they
have sold their soul to the devil and
sometimes people are questioning this if
this is real I can tell you it is real
because I had the situation I was
practicing I didn't make progress and I
was a little bit frustrated and was
questioning myself will we really make
it finally uh because there was no other
option actually for me in life you know
I was thinking I don't want to have this
boring job you know getting up Monday
morning and work for 8 10 hours like
everyone I want to have this boring
lifestyle so this was much more fun and
exciting for me and then in that
situation I remember I didn't again was
not an audible voice but had a
strong um impression in my mind that
somebody told me soul I sell your soul
to the
devil so but it's real I want to tell
you you know I I had this experience
myself
welcome to LED live today we have a very
exciting guest I know I say this every
time but this is an alter boy who went
into the heavy metal band scene and then
God brought him out of that and he's now
a internet YouTube uh social media
evangelist from Germany but you live in
the Netherlands uh welcome teimo Hoffman
thank you so much thank you for having
me I'm excited to hear this whole story
because um God really worked mightily in
your life and uh this really shows you
like how amazing and patient God is with
with us and and brings us you know out
of places that you you might sometimes
look at those people and be like no way
is he coming out and so I praise God
that you're uh taking the call and now
he's spreading the good news via the
Internet so we want to hear a little bit
of your story yes yes so thank you for
having me first of all I want to say
that it's really only by God's grace
that I'm here today where I am
definitely when you hear the story now
it's I mean I was a lost person it's
only by God's grace that I'm here today
so I was raised born in Germany in a
Catholic Family so we went every Sunday
we went to church um we went at strong
Catholics in terms of following the pope
or whatever what he was doing but we
went every Sunday to church I was used
to that I you know I gave my I prayed my
prayers like for my soccer team or for
good weather things like this you know
where children are praying for
and also was raised up in the church um
I followed that that service of an alar
boy so these you know young fellows who
in the Catholic Mass have having
specific tasks that they helping the
priests ringing the bells things like
this is it only on Sunday that you do
that or is this no it's not only on
Sunday but um of actually you know it's
the main main worship time for Catholics
of course so I want to show you a
picture from that time um this an
original picture was taken it's from a
newspaper article actually and uh you
see me on this picture as an alter Bo on
the left side I'm that young fellow who
looks away from the Altar and today this
picture really shows me a lot when I see
this because um you know I turned from
Catholicism away and uh we will hear
about that but uh I remember
specifically in that church um during
the Eucharist um I was there putting
water over the hands of the priest and
while I was doing this I remember I was
about 12 13 years old I was looking up
to that exact crucifix and I asked
myself that question which you often
times feel like Christ died for your
sins but what does that mean so I asked
myself that question what does that
actually mean I heard this so often
times I think we we hear it you know on
the street sometimes when people
approach us um or when we go to whatever
Church Christ died for your sins but I
couldn't really get my head around that
what this actually means but we will
hear in the testim there came a moment
where I realized what that actually
means for me personally so I had not
really a personal relationship to Christ
we never open up the Bible uh I mean in
Catholicism you're generally not um
really encouraged to read your Bible and
have really a personal relationship it's
more about the Saints and Mary and the
pope and these things all these like
more kind of rituals yes more rituals
forms Traditions so I was used to that
not to like a personal savior who wants
to have a personal relationship with me
so this was something which came later
and I remember um in my upbringing in
the Catholic uh or in the Catholic
Church uh we had uh every summer we had
these camp meetings these youth camp
meetings so we came there and uh this
was actually a time where I must say
that we've learned a lot of evil things
I must say you know we started to drink
the first time having relationships with
young ladies things like this you know
and had you know just everything what
the flesh is craving for and I want to
mention it's not just something which is
happening in a Catholic Church alone
this can happen in every church but in
my situation this was what happened and
um so we were not spiritual at all we
had once um during that time we as a
group um we needed to give like a
spiritual talk in the evening and we
hated that we didn't want to do that um
you know we wanted to have fun and so
this is what like my I believed in God
um again I prayed once in a while but
had no relationship ship to Christ I was
more interested in like competitive
Sports uh was big into soccer and other
uh Sports um later bodybuilding and um I
was very interested in music so um for
me this was rock music and heavy metal
music so but we will talk about this
later so um while I was in my youth 14
15 16 years old I I went to a party and
there I met this young lady and she
became actually my girlfriend like a
more serious relationship first really
serious relationship and so one year in
that relationship um I figured out that
this family that they are seventh day
Adventists never heard this term was
totally new to me because I just knew a
little bit about besides Catholicism
okay there are some lutherans but maybe
Baptists I've heard but you know Germany
is mainly it's still though it was you
know a big reform we have protest
protestantism R in Luther all these
things but it's it's now mainly
Catholicism and when it comes to
protestantism there's not much left
anymore in Germany real protestantism so
anyway um I was at this party met this
girl and I found out that uh this whole
family is Seventh Adventist but they
during that time they didn't went to a
local church so but once a year they
went to Switzerland to a kind of camp
meeting Bible study vacation thing so
they asked me would you like to come and
join and I wasn'ted interested in
studying the Bible but I said okay my
girlfriend is there Switzerland is a
beautiful land it's for free you know
just go so we went there and the first
evening I remember we sat there for
supper and I was looking around watching
the people where about 50 60 people and
I watch the table and uh what is on the
table specifically and I was thinking
there's some things missing so I I said
I reached out to quote unquote my
mother-in-law I said to her so you know
where's the coffee where's cheese
where's the meat and all these things
that I'm used to and then she said to me
oh Tim I'm so sorry I forgot to tell you
um you know the whole week we will eat
plant-based I said what plant-based you
want me to
[Music]
eat that moment I looked into the
kitchen I I watched um that lady who was
cooking she didn't look healthy to me
and I was thinking you know you don't
get me with that so um in the afternoon
sometimes I went to the city bought my
meat coffee cheese whatever and in the
evening when the saints quote unquote
went to bed I went into the kitchen and
prepared my food Gorge yes so but anyway
um somehow I got also uh involved in the
Bible studies they met four times a day
I went there and um was listening I was
just I must say really amazed um because
um the person the preacher who was um
giving the talks and he said for example
go to Matthew 24 open this verse or that
passage in the Bible and every one of
them sit sitting there with their own
Bibles and just in a few seconds they
opened up whatever text he said and they
compared and talked about this openly in
the group and I was just amazed and I
was thinking man these people are quite
smart actually you know just amazing um
I never heard about these things and I
must say though I never read the Bible I
believe that must be true because there
must be a foundation there must be
something that we can say okay this is
this is the way to go otherwise you know
follow your heart and all these concept
that you share so often on your channel
here
we know that doesn't work you can't
trust that yeah so I said that must be
true so I was kind of positive um
challenge in that way that I've heard so
many new things doctrinal things I heard
about the Sabbath that it was changed
from Sunday to Saturday they gave me the
historic facts they gave me the Bible
texts uh the state of the Deb all these
things um like even about the spirit of
Prophecy so um I remember I was one week
in that uh um Bible study and actually I
want to show you a picture I was sitting
there it's an original picture on that
balcony there in Switzerland and I
started to pray after a long time again
and I said to God
lord um what is this all about I see you
know the doctrinal things it's very
clear it's it's the opposite from what I
was taught in the Catholic church but I
see it's true it's in the Bible um it's
not something made up I see it clearly
the connections but the most important
part for me was even that I saw that my
picture about Christ changed
before Christ was something or somebody
who was maybe far away because you had
the Saints Mary and so forth in between
and now Christ came really close to me I
saw him totally different and I said to
God lord can I just leave Catholicism
and all these things my picture about
you behind me and go this way go this
way and I didn't hear an audible voice
but God just clearly impressed me and
said yes Teo go for that so that moment
I must say a real burden just was lifted
up from my shoulders really I want to I
want to highlight this um because I
think that this is an important piece
for people especially if you're
confronted with some sort of
life-changing piece of information and
you see it from the Bible truth right
ask God to show you is that the right
way he says he will direct our paths to
the right or to the left right we have
to take him at his word we have to tell
him like Hey this is a whole new way of
thinking is this correct I believe if
you do that he does not ignore you
absolutely if you are open with God and
and humble and sincere he will open up
to you so um I called my mother that
night I told her you know I'm here in
Switzerland with these Adventist she
never heard about 7 Adventist herself
and she was quiet on the phone and she
didn't say much I said Lord I said Mom I
I think the Lord is leading me this way
I think this is the way to go I see you
know what they teach is truth and so and
I said to my mom you know I see this is
the way to go so I want to be baptized I
made that decision actually that night
said why you know wait for something and
I can understand you know um maybe
people will say okay maybe you were not
grounded enough you need more Bible
studies but I had actually this week I
had over 30 Bible studies or whatever
you know yeah so um anyway um my mother
she actually later L years later found
out that she and she is not the person
at all um that way but she she called
actually one of those hotlines where you
speak to a um stranger and they listen
to you you know about your problems I
don't know how you call that like
suicide hotlines like that something
kind of thing something like
psychologist on the other side yes
exactly so and she said to that person I
don't know what I did wrong in my you
know upbringing education with my child
te lost it yes she she she was thinking
he's he's now into this cult and so but
she was uh which was good back then she
was not angry or she was just quiet so
they allowed me to go that way so
actually was baptized the next day on
Sabbath wow so I made this decision and
I wasn't see went back home to Germany I
went to my local church first time and
there were also a little bit like okay
who is this young person you know 17
where is he from he was now baptized
there in Switzerland but whatever so I
started to read the Bible I started to
read even the books from Ellen White
which was a blessing and um but I must
say in the same time still I did not
really understand fully what it means to
have a personal relationship daily to
really get up in the morning spend time
with God and I was still doing the same
things that I was used to uh to do
before like I was still in a
relationship with my girlfriend which
was really yeah way too close how we
live together um I was listening to the
same music Still and I did not realize
that these things um
actually prohibit me to have a closer
walk with God or even might draw me away
from him which actually happened so
after maybe a half year ago um I mean a
half year later yes after
um I found myself again in the situation
that I was listening a lot to having
metal music I went to concerts still and
um I wasn't I don't know I thought
myself that I was thinking okay I don't
know the local church didn't really were
so friendly to me um I had a lot of
strife with my girlfriend broke up with
her and I said to a friend of mine
remember that I said I want still keep
Sabbath but I just go by myself so this
was a mistake obviously because then
from that time on I I I mean it didn't
take didn't take me long until I stopped
actually reading my Bible and praying
things like this was more a burden for
me and more and more music became
interesting for me so um I was listening
to heavy metal music and there were
these bands that I was following for
years since actually I was 10 years old
there was one band I want to see picture
of them this the band Metallica very
famous B wait you used to listen to
these as a 10-year-old yes and your
parents had no problem with it not at
all wow so I was listening to them I
love their music I really adored them I
remember there's a big music festival in
Germany which is called roaring and
100,000 people show up there what does
that mean do you know uh Hing yeah it's
just means like um the place it's uh a
place for where these F1 cars drive it's
a race place a RAC track thing yes so
and this huge place it's actually close
to the town where I live and I went
there every year I was I guess one of
the first persons every year there
showed up and I remember the first year
when when Metallica came and they played
there and um so I knew okay I will see
them in the evening and I went up in
early in the morning and tried to be
first in line uh to be you know way up
front there and actually I ended up that
I was there um in the front but but
during the day they play a lot of bands
before the main band like this evening
Metallica came on stage and I don't know
it took me 12 hours standing there
80,000 people behind you all this
pressure you know you're you're like R
up against that been there many times
yes yes and um so no water you cannot
drink cannot go to the toilet but it's
all for you know that moment right so I
was standing there I remember and they
have this kind of music that they start
out before they come on stage and the
music started and everybody got excited
you know and then the first band members
come came on station I was just standing
in front of the microphone of the lead
singer James headfield and um so I
remember that moment when he came on
stage and he was just maybe a few feet
away from me very close I felt really
like something wow God just came on
stage wow I mean I realized that he's
not God of course but it was really this
this religious feeling adoration God is
yes adoration the god came on stage and
you know so many people think that that
music is neutral doesn't do something
with you but music I mean we know from
the Bible was created for worship that's
right so um music is is is is created by
God for worship reasons so people often
think today okay you get you you need to
go to church worship or you need to
kneel down to worship no what we were
doing you know jumping together just you
know getting wild this is actually it's
the same you know it's adoration like
you said it's worship so
um you know I was this kind of person I
was listening to music a lot I um I was
sometimes sitting hours and hours in
front of my loud speaker just receiving
the music like a meditation thing and um
um I remember one year there was another
band that brought a new record out and
it sounds a little bit weird what I now
say but this this record was back then
for me it was so amazing that sometimes
I could not listen to it because it was
too beautiful for me I couldn't handle I
don't know how how to describe this so
like it would emotionally touch you it
was so strong that I was thinking man
how how do these people you know come up
with these lyrics and these ideas and so
I mean today I understand better talk
about it but then I was just thinking
it's just you know amazing so and there
are many other bands but one of them um
was also the band slip knot that I was
following a lot can these look like
friendly ones yes s so and it's
interesting because I want to show you
specifically this band because um you
know when you compare for example the
music from Metallica to slipnot slip
knot is much faster even it's much more
aggressive even than Metallica this is a
principle how sin works so sin you know
leads you on the path which you go down
and more down the way so um I still was
listening to like Metallica and things
like this but I needed I I saw a craving
for more aggressive things in my life
and more dark things does he have the
word kill tattooed on his hand yep on
his knuckles that's all wow yeah so you
know using all these signs of course
like like pentagrams and found this one
where it says here at the bottom all
hope is gone
yeah and it's interesting that's that's
how I felt actually after a while you
know listening to this music I have a
reason for that um I've looked into the
sort of physics of what it does to our
bodies and they've tested people before
by playing them certain types of music
and then testing what happens in the
brain you know putting them in an fmri
machine and they recognize that even
groups of people that did not hear the
same piece or did not know the same
piece of they weren't familiar with it
were experiencing the music in the same
way so you know I think there's a good
reason why if these guys are sitting
here preaching a message to you that
there's no hope it's gone and you know
we're angry with the world you you by
engaging in that begin to start to like
really think that way yeah for anybody
that thinks that music is only you can
only judge music by what the lyrics say
think about you can play the score of a
horror movie there's no words but a
three-year-old who's never watched a
horror movie in the life will get scared
I mean the the music is scary
and just like if you heard
like you know kids are going to March
around happy music has a spirit to it
it's either happy or sad or scary David
playing for Saul I mean if you're able
to quell whatever Spirit you have inside
of you then it should work as the flip
side as well right you know it can work
for evil and I saw that you know myself
becoming more and more aggressive and
not happy at all so it's interesting
there was a song that they played called
when you five55 I'm 6 remember that so
it's interesting that somehow I love
that song but um I said in my mind I
don't want to listen to that because
there was something still reminding me
you know this number 66 from the Bible
somehow it's too evil you shouldn't
cross that line same with smoking for
example you know I took sometimes drugs
but I was thinking if I start to smoke
again then I really have you know left
God I have left him already in that
situation but I didn't realize so I I
was saying okay if I'm I'm listening to
that song and and start smoking again
then I will be way off but I was so F
fascinated by by the music their band I
I visit a lot of their concerts he's
wearing a crown of thorns yes exactly
yeah I mean he's Joey Jordon he he's
dead now he died yeah he died a while
ago was not overdosed so far as I know
but um I mean you know when he died was
around maybe 1 and half years years ago
I was really sad you know I pray for
these people every day every single day
not just for slipnot for every other a
lot of these people drowning pool lead
singer died um I was yeah a lot of yeah
and I feel so sorry you know for them
yeah they traded in Eternity for this
yes because back then you know I was
looking at these people I was thinking
man that that's happiness that's the the
greatest thing that you can have in life
yeah you know getting all these fame
money girls and whatever but um I wanted
to show you this picture for a reason
because um not just only because he's
wearing this this um Crown but you know
in heavy metal music there are different
genres you have like death metal black
metal all these things speed metal and
uh when it comes to I mean all of that I
believe today is like introduce you into
kind of you know into that you yeah into
Satanism and things like this but when
it comes to Black Metal this is just
open Satanism you know when it comes for
example to bands like Metallica
um they they're not going on stage and
wor Satan openly these guys
are um I wouldn't say that that they do
this openly but there are bands like in
black metal they do this they're openly
Blasphemous they use satanic symbols
yeah but so yeah go ahead in my
rebellious years I went to a panta
concert and I remember they had a big
old pentagram on the on the flag behind
them um I think they even hung the US
flag upside down with with a 666 painted
on it and I just knew I should not be
here but yeah there are bands so there
were these bands black metal and I
always avoided like listening to this
one song 666 um to to listen to Black
Metal because I was thinking if I cross
the border you know I'm I'm just God
cannot reach me anymore just tow the
line yes yes so um but after a while I
just started also to listen to these
bands went to their concerts you know
you saw you see really awful things they
have like pictures in their videos where
they like tearing apart Angels eating
them up yeah yeah it's just awful but
anyway so I wasn't that situation and I
was thinking this is the way to go and
um so I started actually very late it
was just one year after my baptism but I
was 18 I started to practicing guitar
and in the beginning just 5 minutes then
10 minutes an hour a day and it really
um I know after a while really quickly I
practice between 8 to 12 hours a day
every day every single day time job
every single day so I really wanted to
you know uh because I I I realized a
little bit I'm a little bit old so to
say you know I mean 18 is not old but
late in the game late in the game so I
was thinking you know you need to put
effort in it and so I did and then I
called up a friend of mine uh he was
actually a very strong Catholic believer
and his name is Andreas and Andrew and I
said you know Andrew would you like to
to start a heavy metal band with me I
knew he loved heavy metal music like me
but he was also strong Catholic even
much stronger and much stronger involved
in Catholicism than I was so what he did
is um he found himself in a situation
that he was thinking okay I love this
music I want to do actually band but I
don't know if this is in harmony with
God's will so he went up to his Catholic
priest and he said to him okay I have
this request uh what do you think about
it would it be fine if I choose to write
because he he should have been the lead
singer is it fine if I um write
Christian lyrics and we're doing this
kind of music would it be okay for God
and the priest said okay you have my
blessing you can do that as long as you
write chrisan
lyrics so you know I must tell you until
this very day I have no I mean he wrote
Christian lyrics all the time and until
this very day I have no clue actually
what he you know was singing about I
wasn't interested in it because music
you know I mean holy music must have
Holy lyrics definitely but when the
music changes it it's not holy it
doesn't matter what you sing you can
biblically doctrinally correct right but
if you if the music is not holy it will
bring you on a totally different path I
I saw this illustration one time that um
uh Christian ball did and what he did
was he played different types of music
and he had the audience just close their
eyes and tell what kind of emotion this
feels and I that was kind of a thought
experience or experiment that I think
was really telling like yeah you can
easily recognize what feeling these
things produce in you and it seems like
there's a lot of anger and hatred
towards biblical things so even if
you're writing biblical things it's like
the message doesn't really match the
emotion that they're portraying yeah I I
would recommend that too it's called the
distraction dilemma it's on YouTube now
but he gave a really good illustration
talking about how music is like body
language you know I can say I love Jesus
and people what do you think about that
and people are like like oh yeah amen I
agree and then he'll say I love Jesus
they're like well I said the same thing
you know why why are you judging it
different because the body language
didn't match the words and so music is
the same way if you got music like I
love Jesus it's like you're saying I
love Jesus but the emotion is rage anger
death destruction and it doesn't match
so they have to both match and that was
really eye opening for me and even in
Roger mono's experience um when when he
would actually go to this demon cult
that he was part of remember he he said
they sang hyns like with the actual
music of the hyns I mean you would think
like okay you're singing hymns and
you're singing also the same chords and
everything right so the music is like
matching that but because of the context
of what it's done in it is like the
utter most Blasphemous thing you could
do and so yeah it's it it isn't always
necessarily even just the music or the
words is like the setting that that's
put in people are jumping around the
stage right here being debaucherous I
mean you could be playing a him right
here and it'd be wrong yeah it's like a
mockery instead and as for music really
influencing your emotions I used to use
it actually as a drug which sounds funny
but because I was so into hip-hop
dancing fully by college when I had days
that were not feeling so great or I
didn't feel so hot I would actually go
play a song that was kind of like I'm on
top of the world no one can touch me it
would get you that swag it would give
you that feeling and by the time I you
know was getting ready for the day I had
gone through three or four songs I had
that I'm so hot type of feeling and I
could go into the world and be like I'm
good you know I I just remember feeling
that and then realizing one day you're
doping up on thish yeah so it does work
yeah you know would you approach your
your spouse for example say honey I love
you I love you yeah yeah so anyway so we
we started that band and um gather
together some other band members I just
want to show you some pictures of that
time so um you were really into it yes I
was really into it is that a dragon on
your arm yeah it is and a devil head yes
it is and the Devil head I mean it's
amazing I will talk about the tattoos um
soon but I started of course you know
living that lifestyle trying to look
like these people letting my hair grow
long yeah getting
piercings and uh I was really really
into it it was my whole lifestyle and we
we did much effort um playing I mean on
bigger stages step by step um recording
CDs everything um you know and I loved
it to be on stage and and receiving this
this attention I remember this specific
concert in a big city in in Germany I
remember always on our concerts we did
something which is called Wall of Death
oh yeah so this the singer he divides
the audience one um group goes on the
left side and the other half goes on the
rest side on the right side then a
specific point of the song when the
singer gives a sign yes they just you
know yes crash together run into each
other and you know I love this to be in
the audience sometimes I even went from
the stage while I was playing and just
went and joined the audience doing this
oh wow and um then Al or being on stage
and seeing this you know from age how
these young people to your own because
all these songs we you know were our own
songs never covered songs and they just
you know got crazy and and we love that
um but you have control over the yes yes
yes and we knew know when we wrote songs
by the way um in our practicing room
when we wrote the songs we knew already
okay when we play it this way or that
way the crowd will react in this and
that way my younger brother was um a DJ
and actually djed a bunch of of clubs in
his uh early early 20s and I remember he
first sat down with me and he told me
that music has three like acts to it
like a film there's a climax there's a
resolution there's like you know and the
way they play this song in this
particular set will cause the people to
do this and they kind of build on that
and then they let you know the climax
happen and then it like falls down and
it's like wow that that's some serious
intention but anybody who says this
stuff doesn't affect me whatever it's
not going to change my mind I mean this
is prime
example but at the same time I must say
every time when I went from stage or off
stage I realized that you know
this funny lifestyle was not holding on
I could not really you know have that
that kind of piece but it's interesting
we had another um concert on that
evening where this picture was taking um
there we played together with some other
bands and one of these bands um they had
these blood capsules that they used you
know and then this fake blood came out
so that night U we were always very
crazy on stage you're moving a lot
around and I remember in one situation I
was just playing and I was moving in
that direction and our um bass guitarist
um he was moving the opposite direction
so he was coming towards me with his
guitar and his guitar hit me right here
you know and um I can by God's grace
didn't hit my eye I think I would have
lost my eye because immediately I had a
a really big cut here and it started to
to bleed
tremendously so and I was really dizzy
for a moment but in that context we were
playing at a at a contest so and this
was the finals can't quit yeah I
couldn't quit so I was so dizzy you know
I was trying to to catch up again
playing and um so my I remember later
our singer um Andreas he he he he saw me
you know I had all everywhere my face my
clothes was full of blood was just
everything was full of blood and he was
thinking that I took some of these blood
capsules from these other band you know
just to make a
show good job that was amazing
acting so uh we finished the concert
actually we we won actually this contest
W they're like they did the real blood
they wi yeah I like how you're dressed
up in like a nice Church cloth here yeah
exactly so and uh I needed actually to
go that night to the hospital
and get stitches but first you know we
did first partying of course so I just
wanted to show you and tell you this
because we are so into this you know
that you can realize it was just
everything for us really everything such
devotion yes so um we recorded different
um records and you know got involved
with playing with bands which um back
then in that time in Germany became more
famous so we saw that you know we were
not definitely not on the point yet that
we could live
uh from that music or from that
lifestyle but it's interesting when I'm
looking back to these pictures you know
doing these devil horns back then I had
no idea what this actually means it was
for us just something like to to say you
know I I love heavy metal music yeah
rock on and you know um I'm your fellow
buddy or whatever but for me today I see
definitely even I didn't you know do it
on purpose to invite Satan or something
like this I believe today if you're
doing these things even without knowing
that you're welcoming demons s Satan
into your life right yeah so there was
another band um which I want to show you
to make a point is uh this is the B
Machine Head and I love this band this
was one also one of my favorite bands
specifically the lead singer Rob Flynn
and I pray for this guy every day I I I
don't know I really hope that they one
day will see Jesus in their lives um but
there's a principle in the Bible um
where it says that uh we by beholding we
become changed M you know when you see
these um these fellows um and I put a
lot of effort in my image I wanted that
people see me like in a
specific way you know I did also was
very involved back then into
bodybuilding I I I mean I had 15 kog
more than right now or 20 and um yeah I
just wanted to shock people and get
attention and when you see me you know
compared to him you don't see really a a
lucky young man you know or like a happy
young man I must say you know um so
again I got all these tattoos and it's
interesting for me I felt like after
getting my first tattoo I was so excited
but then I was thinking I need another
one I need another one yeah it is really
addictive because in your in your mind I
don't know if it's with every person but
in my mind was like um I will be more
accepted the more shocking I am the more
tattoos I get and when I was looking for
these
specific um pictures that I choose um to
tattoo on my body um I was always um
thinking okay I don't know I need to
find something which I can relate to um
I have for example these you see this
here in my arm I have these Japanese
demons the Oni on yes exactly so and uh
I looked up what is the story behind
this and it actually nothing to do with
my life Wow but I made something up you
know to have a story that I can say okay
you know I can use that and cuz tattoos
are supposed to be meaningful yes
exactly so butterfly down here means I'm
free yeah yeah so uh it's actually today
when I look at my body I have kind of
the great controversy actually tattooed
on my body have this person wrestling
with a dragon like wh of Babylon I have
these these dead people on my body and
everything it's it's crazy but you
really become addicted to it mhm yeah
and I was thinking I need these things
to be more loved more accepted by other
people um but I remember one situation
and when I got a new tattoo I was laying
there in his chair and uh it was
sometimes quite painful I must say you
know when when they go over your arm or
shoulders that's that's quite okay can
handle that that's a sensitive part of
your body but when you go this when you
become here tattoo or like at your
breast or over your ribs this is very
sensitive I remember I had this moment I
was I was laying there I was thinking
what are you doing you I really had this
sober moment what are you doing here
actually just you know just for the
purpose of of being loved and and get
more so to say adoration yourself wow
and but then I shut away this thought
very quickly because I was thinking okay
just go through it you know another
process of five six hours of pain just
go through it and then finally you know
you will be like a level you know higher
there in your experience so do you think
that in the same way that you were
talking about the hand being a gesture
that that is welcoming demons if you
have demons tattooed on you is that kind
of a door opened I would even say not
just only demons just tattoos in general
I believe you know Leviticus 19 is very
clear on that verse facing God's God's
Beauty you know his his creation the
Bible is clear that we shouldn't you
know we are the Holy Temple God wants to
live in us and we shouldn't destroy that
what Christ bought with a high price
when you when you read the the vision of
Ezekiel when he went you know and saw
the temple God showed him what was
happening inside the temple and there
was pictures of gods all on the walls of
the I mean that's that's very um that's
a symbol of our minds and what kind of
like things have we really tattooed on
the inside of our minds you know exactly
yeah so but anyway this was this kind of
image that I wanted to show to the world
and uh we played actually a number of
contests and um I mean was another one
that we won and it's interesting when
you look at these pictures you know we
we we were wild and crazy on stage and
then many years ago I saw this picture
the first time again when we got this
trophy that night you know and looking
at this trophy back then I wouldn't have
recognized that they actually devil
horns you know you get this in your
hands you get this in your hands and you
look at it but you do not realize
actually what it what the symbol is yeah
and today of course when I saw this
picture first time after my conversion I
was thinking man that's crazy you know
how how the devil can deceive you you
know I think just throwing it in your
face like um if you really sit down and
you think about it like there's enough
evidence for you to look back over and
be like was I really deceived or was I
just like buying into this whole world
yeah exactly so um you know my spiritual
my spiritual State back then was very
bad and know that's not me who was
burning the B say say oh this
conversation just got
really that's not me it's Marilyn menson
um but you know I was also a big huge
fan of him went to many concerts and I I
want to show you this picture because
first of all I want to tell you my
spiritual walk with the Lord obviously
was just a mess I didn't believe anymore
in I mean I if somebody would have
approached me and asked me do you
believe in God I would have maybe said
yes I believe in God but obviously I
wasn't following him anymore I remember
one one day I was looking at my Bible in
my room was still there in the Shelf
looking at it and I was thinking ah I
don't know maybe you know man wrote this
book you know
and was not inspired I was thinking
anymore and so um but I want to show you
this picture not only for that reason to
show my spiritual um situation but also
telling people you know they have no
idea when these people and that's not
just obvious people like maril Manson
can be Taylor Swift or whatever these
people are
evangelists this is worship these are
preachers so when they playing their
concerts um I mean with him it's very
obvious because he's talking openly
about it that he's you know member of
the Church of Satan that he wants to you
know lead people away from Christianity
I I I totally believe that these are
evangelists for the for the devil
because if you think about what you're
learning from church um when you listen
to a sermon the the pastor is generally
reading the Bible and giving you a
context of how you should order your
life this is how you should dress this
is how your relationship should be you
should be in a marriage situation if
you're going to engage in a in a Rel
ship with a woman like that right you
need to be married so there all these
things that you're learning about how
should I order my life but this is what
they're promoting the other side of that
do whatever you want throw the rule
books out and and sleep with whoever you
want life's just one big party and
you're only going to live once so you
might as well go down in flames and I
mean it's just like opposite of the
Bible but that's a preacher right there
and the sad part is is who do you think
has more influence this guy or your
preacher and most people people they're
not going to step foot into a satanic
church but they'll go to the concert and
hear Band After Band After band pushing
the same message do what you want have
fun and again it's not even um like
these obvious things like Marl Manson
there are Christians you know who are go
like to Taylor Swifts concerts and you
know and receive their full load of
Witchcraft right or you know people for
some reason people look at Country like
oh it's all about God Guns and freedom
but they're doing the same thing I
cheated on my wife or whatever it's all
the same stuff well and
the coolness Factor right pulls you in
most of the time we don't look at
pastors as being that cool right and
it's hard because they can't compete
with all the world has to offer and I
must say it's a good point you know
something which I believe in why many
specifically young people leave the
church is because these people they
stand for something they're standing up
for something they're strong in their
belief so to say you know their
convictions and often times in in many
churches and even some in our own church
um you do not have really many people
not only pastors but just normal church
members who really that you see that
there are that you can look up to right
you know so I think that's something one
of the main reasons for me that I see
you know I love to follow these people
because you know they're convicted with
their belief system and they're they're
you know PR in the church you do see a
lot of hypocrisy and people that don't
really walk the walk you know they got
the talk but they don't walk it with
these people I mean they're going to
they are who they are yeah definely Ely
I I think um that's that's why the Bible
says I'd rather you be hot or cold Ian
exactly if you're just in the middle and
you're both and you're standing with two
feet in in the world it's like the world
can appreciate somebody that says nope
I'm committing to this thing and I'm
fullon you know putting my whole heart
into it and what does that say to us
Christians I mean so many times Us in
Christianity we've got one foot in the
world and one foot in the church and you
know we're just like think we can eat
our cake and and have our Heyday as well
and tick the box to go to Heaven fire
Insurance you know yeah yeah so you know
I came to a point I must say I was not
always the most talented musician uh but
I put a lot of effort in it and I
believe that we can can make it one day
but there were situations I was
questioning myself if we really will
make it specifically when I was
practicing I don't mean new song or part
in the song and I could not really make
progress so and I remember there was one
specific situation and I must tell you
what I now tell you is um I never heard
about this before um but I know that you
guys you know in your ministry have
shown many Clips when it comes to people
who say that they have sold their soul
to the devil and sometimes people are
questioning this if this is real I can
tell you it is real because I had the
situation I was practicing I didn't make
progress and I was a little bit
frustrated and was questioning myself
will we really make it finally uh
because there was no other option
actually for me in life you know I was
thinking I don't want to have this
boring job you know getting up Monday
morning and work for 8 10 hours like
everyone I don't want to have this
boring lifestyle so this was much more
fun and exciting for me and then in that
situation I remember I didn't again was
not an audible voice but I had a
strong um impression in my mind that
somebody told me soul and sell your soul
to the
devil so and to today you know again I I
didn't hear this Concepts I didn't see
videos about it before whatever I never
heard about this but in that moment I
was reminded somehow that that back then
many years ago was baptized actually his
Adventist found this biblical truth this
this way to go with Jesus and somehow in
that situation praise God about it I I
rejected the thought yeah so I said no I
don't I don't want to go in that
direction somehow even if I was already
into black metal also and all these
things like Satanism somehow I said no I
I don't know that maybe might be not a
good thing to do you wouldn't give up
Eternity for this yeah kind of a thing
yeah so but it's real I want to tell you
you know I I had this experience myself
but again my spiritual work was just on
a on a bad way and um remember I found
this picture we um was one evening we
gave a concert and um we're in this this
place and I found actually a Bible so I
picked up up this Bible I was you see
also P I was drinking the same time and
um I've we around with my other band
members and I started to preach out of
the Bible but not in a holy way more
like in a mocking way I was really
mocking
God and um so I was in a bad spiritual
situation but in that time uh we got a
manager also so a guy who was promising
us you know the world he was telling us
you know you will come together now with
all these American Metal band will'll
play with them and whatever and I
befriended this manager very close I
think I was the one of the band members
who was very close with him I was very
often in his home with his family with
his
children and um I remember always he
told us there's this other friend of him
who has all these connections like to
the record labels these CEOs and
whatever these important people and um
but we never met this other person so
after a few months I remember once I
came to his home his children were there
his wife were there and he was saying oh
Teo I'm so sorry you know this and this
person he was here he just left you
missed him and I was thinking okay you
know it's it's bad again I didn't meet
him and um but I knew that he was a
person who was traveling around the
world that's what he told us so and one
of our band members after a while he was
really questioning what's going on and
then I remember was January 2010 uh this
band member he called me up he said Timo
are you sitting he said yes I'm sitting
okay I need to tell you something he
said I I made my research the last few
days and I want to tell you the guy that
our manager is talking about it's a real
person but he's since 10 years already
he's lying dead at this gravite he's
been deceased uhhuh it's amazing you
know when I've heard this you must
imagine I was fully into this lifestyle
wait a minute wait a wa W my head around
you're going to this person's house his
wife is plained that he's alive yeah
children as well not young children you
know adult children actually and you
know I I must tell you that I was since
14 years I was always asking myself
until this very day how can that be how
can a person just lie around his family
and the play and the family is playing
the same thing yeah like they're buying
into it or unless it's a spirit that's
yeah and that's the point
just recently I must say I came up with
the idea okay you know the Bible is
talking about that the dead are sleeping
and that Satan is deceiving people by
showing up as being their loved ones or
friends dead people familiar spirits
familiar spirits and I mean I have no
proof for that today but I believe it
could be a very option that he really
the whole family maybe even because they
were very much into the ult very much
and I could be that they that they
really you know had conversation with
that person which is a which was a demon
you know and this was was quite shocking
but that moment was the moment where
where I started
to really the the whole world just
crushed down on me you know it was my
whole Dreams Just I mean we still had
the band but of course we got rid of
this manager and um but just everything
collapsed I realized I might be at the
point that I will not make it wow so
what's then and I was just really really
desperate you you know if you are
without Christ if you not have a yeah
something that you can hold on to um I
mean I have a good family they support
me somehow always all these years but um
I was really desperate and it was the
first time since seven or eight years
that I put my guitar aside for a while
and never did this I played really every
day 8 to 10 hours um so and I said okay
what's now you know um
and during that time and I believe that
Gap was working um I saw on German
television I saw a documentary which was
talking about a documentary which was
more which was made about 9911 and this
documentary was mocking that documentary
because this documentary was talking
about 9/11 in a way um giving us other
options what might have been happen that
day so documentary is called loose
change MH mhm so I I was reminded of
that I went to the internet and I was
thinking maybe look it up so I watched
this documentary after one and a half
hours watching that hearing all the
evidence which I believe foreseeing that
these buildings you know they're not
they were brought down yes exactly I
watched that and I was thinking wow you
know my my whole worldview was changed
in this after this one and a half hours
I mean it was not connected to the Bible
yet but I saw I made my studies um study
on the internet about like the New World
Order like the Patriot Act all these
things which change in America and I was
thinking you know we are heading really
in a time of yeah I would say trouble in
a time of trouble without knowing that
the Bible is talking about us but I felt
like what it says in Luke 21 man's heart
failing them for fear and for looking
after those things which are coming on
the earth so I realized there is a
change without knowing or connecting
this now to Bible prophecy and remember
there was this friend of M Mark I said
to him um one night we were sitting in
the car I said to him you know Mark
somehow this reminds me of things which
I've read in the Book of Revelation what
is going on he was actually the only
friend who was listening to me all the
other friends of mine they said oh
you're
crazy there's not a new world order
coming things like this you know teimo
so but anyway in that time I I made I
don't know I studied two or three months
just into that very deep study and
during that time um I believe today that
God
really approached me that way telling me
you know go to your parents house take
this this box of book of books and take
this specific book outside was not the
Bible back then but I took the book The
Great
controversy so this book was written um
in the 19s and 1800s by Ellen Wyatt and
it's an amazing book which shows you
like the history over 2,000 um years of
yeah the fight between good and evil and
how this was displayed and um
Christianity and also tells about the
future what the Bible has to say about
this so while I was reading this book
without any specific purpose of you know
looking for God or whatever um I don't
remember the page or the chapter anymore
but I I realized while I was reading the
book there was this moment that just my
eyes was just immediately open to the
great controversy again and that's an
interesting shift um because it's such a
subtle shift
things around you don't change rapidly
but just the way that you look at them
totally changes I remember when when I
woke up as well I was so into the movie
industry I idolized it was Desiring and
wishing to see you know my picture on
some sort of poster or billboard or
something like that and then when I woke
up it was like I just saw the Warfare in
the Billboards and the people and it's
you just see it all around you and you
just go man all these people don't even
realize where we're standing in the wake
of time yes absolutely so I realized not
only the great controversy I realized
myself a sinner again so I went on my
knees I was really literally crying and
I realized that all those years that
Satan has deceived me you know from that
that moment I was baptized as an
Adventist going back to the world and
that he really yeah deceived me
so um I pray to God to forgiveness of my
sins I committed my life back to God and
um what happened is actually what how
it's quoted in John 14 where it says
that that the comfort of the holy spirit
that he will bring into remembrance all
those things that you have learned you
know before about him and that he will
leave a peace that the world cannot give
you and I felt so overwhelmed um by
arriving at the point that I was looking
in my own strength in the wrong way to
to get this this this actually this
peace in my life and when I found Christ
and the Forgiveness of my sins I was
just really l Lally jumping for joy
wow yes so and another confirmation
which God gave me that I was on the
right track again is that I went on the
internet and I started to watch a series
of a guy um he was talking about all
these new world order things that I knew
already of course he gave some new
information but I knew this stuff now by
now and then he was linking this with
Bible prophecy and then in one
presentation he said that that he's a
Seventh Day Adventist and I was thinking
that's it now this was wter yes exactly
it was him awesome so I watched the
total Onslaught series I I think three
or four times all the videos you know I
watched just into this and um it was
just a strong confirmation for me that
this is it's not not just not just in so
to say quote unquote Christianity but
you know being a Seventh Day Adventist
and um seeing you know what they believe
the doctrines and so forth and um so I
know this is the way to go and um but
Satan didn't stop to to attack me
actually in that time or trying to you
know get hold of me again I remember had
situations waking up in the night and
the first time was really scary I must
say um I felt literally a strong and I I
don't know how to describe but a strong
presence in my room I couldn't see
somebody but I felt really there is
somebody and just all the hairs in my
neck was just standing up and then I
felt this pressure on my on my chest and
pushing down and I couldn't couldn't
breathe anymore and I tried to I was
thinking you know trying to pray to
Jesus but I couldn't you know bring out
the word I tried to to somehow I guess I
I heard to pray loud in that situation
whatever so I tried to uh to to pray
aloud to Jesus but I couldn't say I was
always like
like you know so then I don't know how
long this was but maybe after a few
minutes I could say Jesus know help me
help me help me and then I saw you know
was relief this this this what I believe
today was a demon just left the room and
it happened a few times even after that
but every time when it happened again it
was not a pleasant moment for me but I
realized you know
Jesus he is much much stronger there's
in the name yes Satan and and the demons
that just created beings like us I mean
it's powerful you cannot play around
with Satan but definitely Jesus he is
the creator so uh I got out of the
situations and
um I think that God allowed this to
happen in my life is first of all
because he wanted to make clear to me
very strongly what the great controversy
is about and how real the great
controversy is and to make me strong
that I'm not going again back to the
world Amen so and um I think also today
that God made this clear to me to
because when I later married my wife she
has her own story when it comes to
spiritualism these things and she had a
unique story in that area much more
experience when it comes to like
encounters with demons so that because
sometimes even Christians say today you
know it's not real you know Satan is not
real or the demons your mind is making
it up or whatever no these are very real
experiences very real very real there
are demons and good Angels so I want to
bring you back to this picture here
which I showed you in the beginning
while I was now starting having a
relationship with Christ understanding
what it means to have have like a
devotional life with Christ um remember
I told you that I stood there and was
asking myself the question what does it
mean that Christ died for me in that
time I read another book from Ellen
White which really helped me to
understand the Plan of Salvation how she
explained it in a way was so amazing so
beautiful that for the first time in my
life I remember I started to cry I
really literally understood what it
means that Christ personally died for my
sins and it's an experience that
everyone can make you know if you're
looking for this and that moment when I
realized it what Christ what risk he
took for me MH to die on the cross um I
said to God you know I rededicated my
life to him that night I said if there's
something in my life which is not in
harmony please show it to me of course
there were many things but God goes with
us step by step and then I didn't um was
specific in my prayer but just briefly
after that there were books in my life
now and people conversations that I had
which always went about the topic about
music and specifically rock music so I
realized you know it comes from
backround of of Voodoo music and all
this stuff and I realized you know this
is really not in harmony with the fruits
of the spirit it's more in harmony with
the works of the flesh so and back then
I must say you know as a Catholic um I
had never that Concept in my mind what
the Bible teaches you about uh changing
your character in in a Catholic Church
mainly you believe okay you believe in
God and then it's fine you go to church
it's fine following the tradition it's
fine but that your character needs to be
changed that you need to die to self you
know to the old person to the flesh how
the Bible describes that this was
totally new to me this concept this
amazing concept and so I saw that
playing this music listening to it and
making this music really is out of
harmony with God's will that he can
change me into his image and then I ask
myself the questions like okay why I'm
actually doing this and I could be by
God's grace I could be honest with
myself saying you know actually you're
doing this because you're searching for
love you want to have attention though I
had some fun so to say um but yeah I was
questioning myself and it's interesting
we played another contest um and I must
say you know again God leads us step by
step it's not that I immediately
understood everything about music we
played this concert and I want to show
you this picture and I have a question
for you actually you see on the on the
left side here of that picture what do
you think about when you see me on that
picture you don't look that happy mmm I
always get two answers I ask this
question this one I don't know I I
actually kind of think he looks a little
bit like like peaceful it's interesting
I always get these two answers yeah
really and I can understand people say
either it looks sad and I agree somehow
but on the other side peaceful because I
must say I realized that I did not I was
not into this anymore so much I realized
I had not so much fun anymore to be on
stage and getting all this this
Adoration of the people the moment that
it loses its flavor and you realize
there's something greater than life than
just the focus on me you know I think I
think is a is a freeing experience
absolutely when you're so worried about
your image and so worried about what
people are going to say about you or
think about you there's a lot of energy
that goes into like trying to maintain
that absolutely and then it's like you
back off and you just go but Jesus loves
me and I'm okay that you know yeah it
was for me like that I could take down
this picture of myself it was so heavy
you know always maintaining that image
so from that night this was like the um
before the finals we won again uh even
in newspaper television came they filmed
us and um two weeks after that we should
play the finals and if we would won the
finals we would have again the chance
you know to record a new CD and things
like signed and exactly so and then in
that time of these two weeks one morning
remember I prayed this prayer to God
show me you know whatever it cost that
morning one morning I woke up the first
immediately strong thought in my mind
was leave the band today wow so and I
know the Bible I've learned this very
early in my my experience that that the
Bible says you know when it says today
if you will hear his voice don't Harden
your hearts that's right it's a very
important principle very important I
mean it doesn't mean that you um if you
don't react that God doesn't try to
reach you right he is so merciful and
patient but still I I don't know if I
wouldn't have reacted that that day so I
called up my band members it was not
easy for me I tell you you know they
knew me from this image you know that
person long hair these tattoos drinking
beer talking bad about you know whatever
uh using bad words bad language I called
them up we met in the evening we they
were sitting around the circle I
standing in the midst of them and then I
tried to explain to them my conversion
experience with a conversation for 2
hours and um they mad yeah I tell you no
I mean I I remember our drummer he was
literally sitting like
this literally he couldn't and I can
understand him that he couldn't
understand it because conversion is a
miracle MH I mean even Satan cannot
understand that so and another band
member he said to me Timo you're so
selfish how can you leave the band now
you know we need to play this very
important concert now how can you leave
the band now and and isn't that
interesting that's like calling the
kettle black right you're saying he's
being selfish when you're sitting there
going you know what like I like my
heart's not in this anymore and and you
can really see the band memb hearts at
that point because they're like well
this is going to prevent us from doing
XY or Z and you know they're
self-reflecting on your decision yeah
exactly but I must say that God gave me
the grace to go through that situation
which was tough I prayed a lot before we
met um because it it it means for you
that you really we have this expression
in German that you say you like get rid
of your pants you just let loose and
everybody can see you like naked so to
say the naked truth yes the naked truth
and you know getting this getting rid of
this image of the strong person and
everything you know so I think it was a
like a good test that God gave me and um
so that night I said You know guys I
love you but I cannot do these things
with you anymore I see it's out of
harmony with God's will it will lead me
back you know to where I was before so
this is verse in the Bible Paul talks
about in Romans 1: 16 where it says for
I'm not ashamed of the gospel of Christ
for is the power of God unto salvation
to everyone that believeth and I believe
that today very much seeing how God has
led me you know the experience of giving
me the grace to overcome changing my
character all these things there are
many Idols in my life uh not only the
the music but one thing that I really
enjoyed I must say you know my guitars
for example very expensive guitars I had
uh specifically for this kind of music I
always you know like when you see these
big rock star they sometimes take these
guitars destroy them on stage I never I
I tried um maybe I didn't try but I
wanted to do this always on stage but I
didn't do it because I was hesitating or
so expensive guitar and I love this
guitar actually was like my baby but
after my conversion it was just nothing
to me anymore you know I went home
actually that night I was it was still
tough on me I was kneeling down I was
crying like a little baby I must say I
said to God Lord I hope it was the right
thing because you know Satan was still
trying to put these doubts in your mind
but that night this the same person
actually who wrote me this me uh who
told me from the band you were so
selfish he wrote me a message telling me
teimo I know you now so since so many
years and I I don't understand what
happened to you to be honest but I know
you're not crazy this gave me a lot of
comfort I must say so and then the next
morning I woke up and I had just totally
completely peace I never went back to
heavy metal music playing this kind of
music I just destroyed all my CDs taking
off my posters and everything and
destroyed my guitars and it was kind of
fun to do that back then wow yeah you
got you got your wish yeah yes exactly
and uh I again there were many Idols in
my life and one of them which I didn't
mention yet was really uh movies also I
was very much into movies all the time
you know when I was bored or I just went
into this fantasy world and getting out
of this boring
life and um very much also into
competitive Sports and I remember I just
became a fresh Adventist again I left
the band just a few months back into the
church and um so we had a meeting a
youth meeting a big youth meeting in
Germany and um there came this guy over
from the US and he gave some
presentations about Hollywood so
remember that guy interesting who's that
guy with the funny hair to oh my so I
mean that picture was not from Germany
it's it's a different place but you look
the same then and you were talking gave
you gave your testimony and gave a few
presentations back then about
Battlefield this series Battlefield
Hollywood and I was sitting there and I
was just I knew all these names all
these movies and you showed all these
things like people these these actors
channeling you know demon possess and
all this stuff and I was sitting there
for hours and I was just all the time
grapping my friend next to me saying
have you seen this what have you heard
this what you said you know just
amazing so this was I must tell you
today you know I really appreciate what
you guys doing I want to say this
because um I believe that um your
ministry is a blessing for many many
people and sometimes Christian do not
really value what you guys doing cuz
they think oh we shouldn't talk about
these things you know it's evil and why
expose why you know expose people to
these things but you must understand
there are people outside like me and
there are thousands outside who are who
are not in the church you cannot reach
them you know putting them the Bible in
their hand yeah you know back then when
I read the book from Ellen White this
helped me you know to come back to
Christ so that's why I must say you know
um for me personally your ministry until
this very day it's also huge blessing
praise God it's been a really neat
journey and I I I think kind of one of
the things that made me excited to go
around and talk about these issues
because this was my idol the the movie
industry was was something that I held
up and just desired with all of my
mental capacity and it led me astray and
so when I was able to get away from that
and you know the the Lord just really
helped to tear down those Idols in my my
heart I was I just want I saw other
people that were engaged in the same
behavior and I said you know hey if you
could learn something from from these
great never would have dreamed it would
have turned into what it did but praise
God yeah thank you so much so let me
just um tell you at the end a little bit
about my family and what happened also
to um friends of mine so you know I was
so o overwhelmed with this new um
relationship that I started with Christ
this treasure I found I just it you know
came out of me all the time I told
people about my family sometimes maybe a
little bit too much so you know I went
for example I I went to my brother told
him four hours about like you know
everything about Freemasonry connecting
this with Bible prophecy and then at the
end he said to me okay you want me like
to have a ticket for heaven or something
like this I said yeah somehow you know I
didn't know how to express my my myself
so well back then but I started to share
with my family and there was one
situation I was with my brother and um
my mother in the room and shared with
them about my my faith and um my my
father he came home from work and he saw
the situation and he felt like that I
was kind of attacking my my mother so he
came in between us came very close to my
face and he said to me in a very angry
voice Teo sto that you destroy the
family with your new beliefs and
convictions everything you know they're
still Catholics so and um that moment I
must tell you my relationship with my
father was very bad um sometimes when he
came into the room just to say hello
after work and I was practicing I just
yelled at him and said go out of the
room you know it was this kind of
relationship because I was focusing I
was thinking you know don't you see you
know I'm I was so selfish but anyway so
that moment when my father was yelling
at me I didn't yell back I just had
tears in my eyes because I was just
overwhelmed in a negative way thinking
you know how can they not see this it's
so you know meaningful and this is all
this is what life is all about and gives
you so much peace and joy so I kept
praying for my parents after a while my
father he came to me after a few weeks
and he started to ask specific questions
those kind of questions where you know
okay the holy spirit is working on him I
said to him Dad please let me give you
this book I gave you the great
controversy I said please read this so
in the beginning I had a little bit hard
time reading it after a few
weeks he came back to me in the living
room and he was crying he embraced me
and he said teimo I needed to become 56
years old that God sends me my son
literal son to show me what is the truth
wow that moment on he started to study
the Bible uh he went with me to church
and he said to me do you remember that
situation that we had in the living room
a few weeks ago I said of course I
remember that where I was yelling at you
I said yes I'm remember that and he said
do you know why I gave it a chance H to
read that and arrive here you didn't
react I didn't react in a bad way and
you know it's interesting Proverbs 15:1
it says a soft answer turth away wrath
but Grievious words stir up anger he
said I saw something in your eyes that I
saw something
is is different with him something is
different with him this very moment gave
him the chance to investigate for
himself and say yes you know what the
Bible has to say it's it's the truth of
of course first of all but it's also
different from what I have been taught
you know 56 years ago it's interesting
my father it's the Own Story by itself
he was approached by Adventist four
times in his life wow yes four times so
finally when I became Adventist he
turned around and actually um making a
long story short my mother she now
thought now my son my my husband there
are now in this cult and uh she was in
the beginning not sure about this but we
studied what watched some videos talked
prayed sometimes together but she was
still a little bit hesitating but I
invited my parents also to Switzerland
to come to this Bible study week and um
I was praying for my father he was
already here in in the church I was
thinking okay he would be good time for
him to be baptized my mother she opened
up more and more during this week I
really saw her change really saw it
change and then uh my mother Friday she
came to me and she said Okay Teo I I got
it and she said I want to go that way I
want to be baptized wow 2 hours later
she didn't went to my father she went to
me first 2 hours later my father came to
me he didn't went to my mother went
first to me he said Teo I want to be
baptized so they were both baptized and
I was just a blessing to see um how this
changed in our family and my father
became really a Bible student and then
there was my older brother and he was
kind of sometimes into Gothic like you
mik key and
um yeah he had his ups and downs in life
and I've talked with him about faith he
was sometimes open sometimes was
rejecting it again but he had his
experiences there was one night I
remember that he was lying in bed and
somebody took his blanket away in the
night in the middle of the night wow so
he took it again then again was to
taking away from him so I believe also
today that demons you know trying trying
to to scare him but finally uh praise
God he gave up on his life he was
baptized it was a blessing many years
and so then we as a family um you know
uh stood up for Christ and for the
biblical Faith which I believe today and
I mean we are not a perfect family today
we have our up and down still but we
know today we can kneel down and we can
pray together and so beautiful like
those verses in the end of Malachi you
know that that will turn the hearts of
the sons to the fathers and the fathers
to the sons you know I think all of us
have a witnessing opportunity I mean I'm
I'm I'm pretty sure there's somebody in
our short immediate close term family
unit that is not walking with the Lord
and you know to pray for them pray for
their change you know sometimes it's
it's a a quick thing and sometimes it
takes years yeah yeah we should never
give up you know I was praying for my
friends there was this friend Mark I
mentioned it to you he was not band
member but he was traveling with us and
um I shared with him my faith then and
he he was also ala boy and he said yeah
makes sense what you're sharing with me
but what about Evolution I said can we
please sit down and watch one of these
presentations from this guy from South
Africa I said okay let's watch it so we
watched the first presentation from
Walter 5 Evolution and
creation and he watched that after an
hour he was laughing about himself
because it was the first time that he
listened to the opposite or maybe the
the other side of the coin you know and
he was saying man I never heard about
this information and it it just makes
sense so he made his his stand for
Christ he was baptized beauti he was
baptized 7 Adventist let me once go back
to the picture of this friend of mine um
Andreas the guy who the Catholic guy who
which I've started the band with he's
your singer yes he was the singer and I
must say there was a time that we um we
yeah we kicked him out of the band it's
a longer story but we kicked him out of
the band for some reasons we got a new
singer and our friendship really broke
up you know was a bad situation and when
I converted I went to him God gave me
the grace and strength to apologize to
him I said you know what's what's wrong
what we did and personally what I did to
you what I say I said even some bad
things about his family so I apologized
to him and even to his family and um so
somehow I saw that he appreciated it but
was still you know not really like a
warm feeling or situation between us and
then but I I kept praying for him and
the other b band members every day and
then about I I was about 6 years while
I'm 2016 when I was in the faith um one
day he called me up he was in the US
here and he said I'm sitting right now
Teo in the bus there's this guy in front
of me reading a newspaper it was a
picture of the Pope and he said why are
you 7thday Adventist still believe that
the pope is the Antichrist power of
Bible prophecy I said okay Andreas if
you come back to Germany I tell you so
he came back and then we had a
discussion he brought even his cousin
with him and we did not just talk about
the pope we talked about everything so
what the Bible has to say at the end I
gave him a great controversy and it's a
unique story for himself many things
happen in his life but this was one part
which I could play a part of in his
situation and then he started to
investigate he read the book and one
evening he called me up he said Teo Teo
did you know that the Catholic Church
changed the Ten Commandments I said
Andreas had told you a 100 times already
before you know 100 times but God knows
when the time is and it goes into his
heart he was not ready back then the
soil has to be prepared so he quit with
Catholicism this was a huge step for him
because his family is very much involved
they they know all these Bishops
Cardinals in Germany you know they're
close with them so he made this step out
of Catholic ISM and um he just
investigated went to the Baptist went
there and there and I said you just go
there study with them see but pray be
humble and see that God leads you into
all truth and then I remember once one
Friday he called me up he said what are
we doing tomorrow I said I have to
preach in that church he said okay I
will join you he went there and in the
car he said it's so crazy Timo I'm
sitting here now with you on the Sabbath
he understood now the Sabbath you know
it's it's on on it's on Saturday 7th day
he said okay you know back then when you
became Adventist I was thinking the
Protestants have stolen my best friend
wow and now I'm sitting here with you
going to an Adventist Church listening
preaching you know an Adventist sermon
which you will preach today it's so
crazy and this was an amazing um moment
because then um short while after that
he took a stand he was baptized became
Seventh Day Adventist and we said you
know before we we work together for for
Satan now we can serve the Lord in all
wow the whole band converted no no no
not the whole band was just him so far
but we keep praying and I mean they see
they knew Mark very well you know the
other guy the friend of mine was not a
band member but and they know of Andreas
obviously but they see you know there's
something going on it's not just teimo
you know who who couldn't go into um
because people said oh this one extreme
he left the music now he's going another
extreme because he yeah because he
couldn't make it here you know now he's
going different he becomes religious or
something like this so um yeah from that
moment on to wrap it up now you know I
left the music everything behind me and
God gave me really a Ministry uh I had
such a burden for reaching out to people
one of those things that you mentioned
in the beginning is like we started a
YouTube channel and uh by God's grace
God could use that to to reach out to
people which is a blessing I praise him
for that um you know got education and
like medical missionary rework these
things my wife and I were really
involved in that and by the way my wife
she came into my life which is a great
blessing she has her unique story um but
I believe that really from the bottom of
my heart she's Dutch and lives in the
Netherlands yes exactly so denque um who
works with us she she was also from the
Netherlands and came over here to work
with us so the Dutch are taking over
right exactly so God gave us together
Ministry When we married and um you know
doing different things like preaching
giving cooking classes talking about
health and doing the things on YouTube
and um so we had together for seven
years we had this ministry which was a
plant-based U health food store that we
use like a center of influence to reach
out to people we had good experience
back then there and right now we see
that God is leading us we're right now
here in Tennessee actually for a few
months following uh training on a farm
and uh so because we believe that
there's a call even for Christian
Farmers very necessary you know when you
study the book education for example and
understand the concept of what true
education really is all about so that's
something that uh we up to right now and
uh we love that and I just can praise
God for how he led me and how it says in
Revelation 12 last verse it says and
they overcame him by the blood of the
lamb and by the word of the testimony
and they did not love their lives unto
death so you know I was at this point
that God reached out to me when I was 17
unfortunately I I left him and way of
truth I went back to the world and God
has had really Grace I was mocking him I
was really I know was a bad person I was
really a lot of sin in my life um but
it's just amazing every morning when I
wake up literally every morning I just
praise God
and tell him you know it's just you're
so merciful that you reach out to a
person like me you know who was mocking
you and doing all these bad I still you
know what I did had still has still in
bad influence on people's lives
today um I regret that very much but God
is so merciful he forgives you and I can
just you know tell everyone to whatever
situation you are in if you're afraid to
reach out to God or if you know persons
that you think oh they will never you
know accept Christ
God knows how you can reach you and um
so I pray now that is my prayer that God
stay me
faithful um that I'm not loving my own
life but be faithful until the very end
it's so beautiful I I never tired of
hearing about a story of of someone that
is very unlikely you wouldn't think like
this guy's someday going to be an
evangelist you know you see pictures of
him and it's like wow you are definitely
in the enemy's camp and when when God
gets a hold of your heart I also have
really appreciated the gentleness that
he wins us back it's not like he's like
okay you need to sit in the corner and
think about this for you know 3 years
before I let you give you an opportunity
it's like he built a beautiful Ministry
around you your you and your wife
traveling together and sharing the
gospel I mean you're doing more than
many church members who have been in the
church the whole time and and it's
beautiful to see that and that really
speaks to when God wins your heart you
you can't be silent you need to just
like like guys have you heard this
before I mean this is this is the most
amazing thing in the world and if you
have something amazing why would you why
would you not want other people to
experience that as well so thank you so
much for sharing and uh we'll put a link
in uh the description below to his uh
YouTube page um but he's got a lot of
really neat material um most of it's in
German I think yeah but you can click at
least the English the English stuff but
um you know thank you so much for
stopping by and uh joining in on this
conversation listen if you learned
anything from today's talk I hope you
learned this there is no one that is too
far outside that God cannot reach and
you know some of the most unlikely
people that you think nah I'm not going
to waste my time praying for them look
at this example right here pray for
those I love the fact that you brought
up you're praying for the guys from
slipnot I mean is anyone else praying
praying for those guys we all need
prayer and uh wouldn't it be amazing if
one of those guys could be turned over
for the gospel and what a what an
amazing testimony that would be um
please like this video share it to
someone you know that would be uh very
interested in this particular topic and
um you know a little thing that you can
do for our ministry um to help support
what we do hit the Subscribe button we
got lots of the content just like this
and uh that just helps us in the
algorithm down the road to get these
messages out and it's a very simple
thing for you to do but if you if you
want to give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to our Channel that'd be
awesome and otherwise we want your
prayers and we thank you for stopping by
and listening we'll see you guys next
week if you're looking for good
wholesome educational content for your
children subscribe to our new channel
little like kids
[Music]
he